[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy recently European Commission
first vice president Franz timmermans
hosted a roundtable with Imams from
Belgium Bulgaria France Germany Italy
and the Netherlands he had a message for
them that they doubtlessly welcomed he
said the Commission is strongly
committed to promoting diversity in
Europe Islam is part of our history
this LOM is part of our present and
Islam will be part of our future there's
no doubt that Timmerman's statement is
true but not quite in the way that he
obviously meant Timmerman's did hint
that he was aware Europe might not
travel a smooth and Placid path to the
glorious multicultural future when he
said the way we help our citizens
whatever their background may be to
embrace the diversity that is a reality
in European societies is going to
determine much of our collective future
in 2015 timmermans said diversity is now
in some parts of Europe seen as a threat
diversity comes with challenges but
diversity is humanity's destiny there is
not going to be even in the remotest
places of this planet a nation that will
not see diversity in its future he
didn't say anything about the fact that
many majority Muslim countries have been
growing less diverse in recent decades
while Europe grows more so nor did he
explain how these Muslim countries were
ever going to become diverse since no
one is challenging them to do so
timmermans did say Europe will be
diverse like all other parts of the
world will be diverse the only question
is how do we deal with that diversity
and my answer to that is by ensuring
that our values determine how we deal
with diversity and not giving up our
values to refuse diversity that will
bring us down as a society so you see we
will be diverse by being diverse he's a
deep thinker Timmerman's concluded
ominously if we don't get this right I
truly believe Europe will not remain the
Europe we built Europe will not remain a
place of peace and freedom for very long
he's right again in that but also
not in the way he means in reality it is
because of his diversity project that
Europe might not remain a place of peace
and freedom timmermans is right
Islam is a part of European history it
is certainly a part of its present and
most assuredly will be in its future and
its presence in Europe has from the
beginning led to the end of peace and
freedom for Europeans in my forthcoming
book the history of jihad from Muhammad
to Isis I detail how the Islamic Jihad
EES first attacked Europe in the seventh
century as Islam itself was coming into
being and continued to harass and
terrorize Europeans for centuries
thereafter if Timmerman's and other
European leaders knew the history of the
jihad against Europe and elsewhere that
I detail in the book they might not be
so sanguine about Islam's presence on
the continent to take just one notorious
example after over 700 years of trying
the Warriors of jihad finally entered
Constantinople on May 29th 1453 when
they did they made the streets run with
rivers of blood
Muslims raided monasteries and convents
killing or enslaving their inhabitants
and plundered private houses they
entered the agia sofia which for nearly
a thousand years had been the grandest
church in the Christian world the
Muslims then killed the elderly and weak
and led the rest off into slavery the
Byzantine scholar besar Ian wrote to the
Doge of Venice in July 1453 just two
months after this happened
saying that Constantinople had been in
his words sacked by the most inhuman
barbarians and the most savage enemies
of the Christian faith by the fiercest
of wild beasts the public treasury has
been consumed private wealth has been
destroyed the temples have been stripped
of gold silver jewels the relics of the
saints and other most precious ornaments
men have been butchered like cattle
women abducted virgins ravished and
children snatched from the arms of their
parents when the slaughter and the
pillage was finished mehmed ii the
Conqueror of Constantinople ordered an
Islamic scholar to mount the high pulpit
within the argue Sophia and declared
that there was no god but Allah and
Muhammad was his prophet the Magnificent
old church once the grandest in all of
was turned into a mosque hundreds of
other churches in Constantinople and
elsewhere suffered the same fate
millions of Christians joined the ranks
of the dim ease others were enslaved and
many were killed the Muslim advances in
Europe generally followed this pattern
even the vaunted proto multicultural
paradise of Muslim Spain was only
remotely liveable for Christians and
Jews when they passively accepted the
daily harassment and discrimination
mandated for non-muslims in Islamic law
if timmermans knew the history of Islam
in Europe would it really make a
difference maybe timmermans and the rest
of the European political elites do know
this history and they know what's coming
and they just don't care as long as
their diversity imperative stays on
track but those are the only two choices
timmermans and his colleagues are either
suicidally ignorant or treasonous beyond
measure
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]